les musulmans ont deux grandes fêtes
dans l'année donc la fête de a fitre qui
célèbre la fin du Ramadan et la fête de
kir qui est la fête donc d'Abraham le
mois de Ramadan est un mois d'exercice
spirituel où pendant un mois les
musulmans sefforcent de trouver la
proximité divine et après avoir montré
tout leur amour à Dieu et bien Laï c'est
le jour de la récompense donc cette
cette journée aujourd'hui et bien
symbolise aussi ce moment de ferveur qui
a été le mois du Ramadan pour l'ensemble
de la communauté musul de la réunion du
monde entier pas longtemps c'était le
ramadan que je fais je feris le
bilan suisje bon ou
meilleur c'est quand même la Parole de
Dieu
et c'est quand même quel quelque chose
d'important pour nous les musulmans
c'est une grande émotion c'est juste un
moment de pouvoir fêter ce bonheur qui
est la fête de Laï avec toutes nos
autres communautés frères et avec tous
nos frères et sœurs
Ronn FO se l et que le vice se
complimente que la peur nous regarde de
si haut et Lucifer rigole autour de nous
ça brûle onvite de faire du bien onvite
faire du mal on sait pas quel côté
moi j'ai fait tellement d'erreur et je
demande
pardon alors l'islam à la Réunion c'est
quelque chose d'extraordinaire
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a un mélange total
des des cultures à tel point que l'islam
s'intègre automatiquement dans toutes
les religions qui existent à la Réunion
comment Viton l'islam à la Réunion je
serais tenté dire c'est un islam
extrêmement Pacifique où la communauté
est très bien intégrée vit au rythme des
prières au rythme des mosquées et la
communauté musulmane comment dirais-je
est véritablement solidaire et quel
regard comment vous voyez cet islam à la
Réunion c'est magnifique c'est très
calme
très c'est moi qui a visité le premier
cons de a visité le grande mosquée euh
de Saint Denis c'est vrai qu'en tant
qu'élue républicaine je suis toujours
heureuse depuis bientôt 10 ans de
recevoir ici chaque année chaque
confession qui a à la Réunion une
présence forte dans la vie et dans le
cœur des Réunionnais et des
Réunionnaises ici chaque année se fait
le DIP ali se fête la Noël le 24
décembre ici chaque année se fête la
fête de guwendi ici chaque année nous
fêtons la fête de Laï mais nous recevons
aussi les boudhies nous recevons la
communauté juive parce que c'est une des
grandes religions du monde et que les
religion n'ont pas été mises en place
pour se faire la guerre mais bien pour
faire en sorte que les hommes vivent en
paix